[Applause]
hi everyone welcome to my talks here
some days we were - hi my name is
Catherine and not a next thing isn't
working ok so at first I have to make
confession to you and the confession is
I love makeup tutorials and I really
enjoy watching them on YouTube and so I
have one favorite YouTube artist and so
this person is a professional makeup
artist and special effects makeup artist
in Hollywood and I love her videos
because she focuses mostly on tutorials
some of our about beauty makeup others
are about special effects makeup like
zombies and stuff and on top she has a
very cute dog and for me it is enough to
love her but she has many many fans that
love her too and so because they love
her and because she's a professional
makeup artist in Hollywood a lot of
people ask her for product
recommendations because she knows her
stuff and also people want to recreate
the look she is creating and hopefully
with the same products it gives the same
outcome and also other people like to
feel closer to this artist by using
their products so far so good that's
more or less a win-win situation for
everybody but sometimes bad things
happens and this is when the product
becomes equal to the person and then
someone maybe has something to criticize
maybe it's a legit criticism about one
of the products but then for fans it
becomes that they are criticizing the
artist and fans really march in and say
oh yeah you cannot do that and this
creates a very toxic environment where
people are silenced or too afraid to
speak up even though there is a legit
point on criticizing something but this
is not track on does a CSS con so let's
talk a little
at CSS birthdays things see this is the
makeup of the web because you can put
litter on it and so here we as a family
the deaf community and we also have our
influencers and ninja developers ten
times developers our rock stars and we
love them and also their products me
love and products that get criticized
and why are we criticizing again the
person so we have the same toxic
environment as the people on YouTube and
makeup oh my god
things like when you're get happen so
everybody maybe follow that link if they
want to know what's on so let's just say
the hyper suil and the thing is the hack
was not only real ever since we have
things like YouTube and Instagram and
everything no does assault justice as
old as the you are a society that formed
in 1660 and asked this problem of having
influences back in the day it was mostly
a Lord that said something is very old
and then you had someone else that wants
to criticize the sword and they say yeah
but you cannot criticize this person
he's rich she's wealthy he's a lord and
so I said you know what no yours Envy
ever that's our motto no Leo's endeavor
is Latin and translates to take nobody's
word for it and it is described as an
expression after determination our
fellows to withstand the authority of to
verify all statements by an appeal to
facts determined by experiment because
my should you believe me I don't even
have 500 followers on Twitter instead I
want to let the facts speak for me okay
but before we jump into shiny tools and
stuff let's ask a question what is wrong
with CSS I mean y'all here we all love
CSS but
something is wrong and yeah one thing
that is very wrong is the first paint
because science and statistics have
shown that when the first paint is
delayed already by half a second the
user satisfaction really decreases and
also with the user satisfaction our
conversion rate decreases because in
classic web the browser does dis it
starts downloading the HTML and then
when it's finished with the HTML it
starts downloading the CSS and only when
it has both downloaded and interpreted
it can start painting so which means
that he is as render blocking so it
keeps our user from seeing our page and
therefore sees as the bad guy and so we
have to bring it as quick and as soon as
possible to our users ok so what can we
do about that let's let's fix it so
first of all there is a very nice thing
that people from browsers and other
people have done and this is HTTP 2
because HTTP 2 has the approach of
starting HTML and starting C that's at
the same time because this is able to
have multiple downloads with the same
TCP connection which means we are faster
but still sometimes the CSS file can be
very big I can tell you like in one
company I worked I had a CSS file that
was nearly 1 megabyte so this was a ruby
monolith so yes so what can we do we can
also split our CSS into meaningful parts
because we only need to have two CSS of
the stuff we show and so we are already
very smart and putting our HTML on our
JavaScript so why not create one chunk
of both of them and only render stuff we
need to see right now and cut this in
small chunks which means
this great solution because we only
download what is necessary and don't
delay any rendering okay now finally
tools so one very very popular tool to
approach the CSS and J's thing is called
sty components it is an NPM package for
react and yeah in nine components you
are now finally allowed to get rid of
that dot CSS file you just write all
your Styles in your JavaScript and then
you can probably configure it with the
use of bubble and here Jeremy screaming
and if you don't want to use sty
components there are other packages some
would be mentioning worth mentioning is
emotional and then you just add it to
your package in your react and then you
import style from stock components then
you write your CSS and your JavaScript
and then you can return it as a
higher-order component and just use it
as any other react up on it great
another approach is a different kind
where you let your build process work
for you and for that there are bungalo -
it's like web pack so this is a bundle
for node and this works like that that
it's collecting all your assets like
your CSS combines it with your
JavaScript and then splits it into small
chunks so exactly what we want and then
of course it has a huge configuration
possibility yada yada and if you don't
want to use webpack there's a popular
alternative which is called parcel and
so as I said you just can import a
normal vanilla CSS file or a CSS file if
you want and then configure in the
bubble convict as CSS our CSS loader
great okay so as I said we're doing
fact-checking here this is science so
what are we going to look into so first
of all we want to solve our render
blocking problems so we want to go fast
and then another very famous problem
we heard from Mike is scoping and naming
and um has to be heard from earlier we
also are super fancy about stage so
let's you state question number one now
have you fast yet I said we're going to
experiment but we just my cat call and
for Karl I built a website which I'm
going to use to experiment
it's called Park Club and it pops up you
can upload a picture wait something
about you and other cats can comment and
if you want to also play along with it
after this talk and here's to get up to
it and so does my experiment it's just a
very tiny react application and I have
set it up in three variations one is
with vanilla CSS this is going to be my
control group and so there I just have
written one CSS file and this one CSS
file I included in the index dot HTML
the other one version is the one with
backpack where I have also set up a CSS
loader and then of course the third
variation is the components and then I
have used the performance tool on the
Chrome browser and as you can see in the
frame part of the performance tool we
can see that on the mark of 250
milliseconds we have our first
meaningful render so the thing I said
earlier that we have a blank page before
we actually see it is true and it takes
around 500 milliseconds for our tiny
tests to fully be loaded and in a
summary part of the performance so you
can see how many time we spend on
rendering loading and scripting and
painting but I focused mostly on loading
and scripting because so loading is
influenced by the file of file size and
of course by the connection of the user
because nobody wants to travel the
deutsche bahn and surf
so and then scripting time which is
influenced by the complexity of our
script and of course again the file size
which goes along with the complexity and
then it is also dependent on the user's
device so if someone has a very old
cranky phone this will also be heavily
influencing our scripting time and so I
did just test several times and
calculated an average and so we can see
data for the vanilla CSS we have around
60 milliseconds floating around 100
milliseconds of scripting and to prove
my other argument that the bigger the
file the more loading time we have I
just added for fun bootstrap CSS to it I
didn't even use any of the bootstrap I
just included it also in the HTML file
and when I had done that the loading
time increased already significantly as
I set aside average numbers I calculated
over I don't know how many times so then
the next approach was the web pack one
where we decreased again our loading
time because even though the bootstrap
was still there it wasn't used so it's
not downloaded and also understand
component side we had an even more
decrease of the loading time but if you
look close there is a huge and
significant increase on the scripting
time and you might have heard this
already the people say the CSS and J's
is bad on your performance and so we
asked ourselves why is that so if you
now look in the virtual DOM and denotes
that the visual Thomas rendering so as I
said I have the same set up for all of
my variations and on the component side
it's the same so this is the few of the
components for the vanilla CSS and the
web pack version so where we can see I
have a blog I have a button component
and all those kind of things but when we
have a look at the one from site
components
it doesn't even fit on the screen and
now we can read that okay so
implementation looks like this I have my
style block container and then I
returned this higher-order component
which I have to do in order to be able
to use the style components while on the
epic variation I only can just add a
class to it like I would normally do and
this means that instead components for
every normal container I have a
higher-order container that is giving me
my CSS and this is also context using so
I have around four nodes instead of one
when I have to backpack variation so
what did we learn now so yeah if you
have a very small website you still can
use modular CSS but be warned so if the
CSS and J's approach is very strong the
bigger hue application is growing
because it can not grow over a certain
threshold by chunking your JavaScript
and your CSS together but be aware there
is definitely a scripting time increase
so your performance is getting lower the
more of the JavaScript you're using okay
number two can we finally scope now okey
the promise of style component is that
we don't have to think about this
anymore so it's a common problem you
probably have everybody can not think a
second about what color this button has
it's plum of course even though the
primary classes later in the file the
class that is combining two class names
is stronger and this is why we very
often end up in a complex thing like
this we just add more classes to a
component in order to give it finally
the style we want it and this is bad
nobody can remember any of these classes
later and also just brings you in a spot
where you don't feel safe to delete any
of
CSS and this is how you end up in a CSS
file that's one megabyte big
okay so sty components what can you do
for us as I said we have this component
with style and the higher-order
component and when we render this it
generates a class for us and the package
itself promises us that this is more or
less an ID so it's unique and it will
only be used one time on the same
component and it also uses this giberish
class name to add our Styles here so
we're sure this no leaking it is always
one strong selector awesome
six months later someone comes in and
says oh we have a park on that component
so you look in your development tools
and the questions start evolving like
where the heck is that code from income
coming from and what do these classes
mean I mean why is it purple is it meant
to be like the main action is it only
for this page I have no clue and why
always so I did go to github and looked
at the issues but if I did something
wrong and one of the contributors
answered and said like oh this is done
by intent we want to have two classes
with only one is styled so one of them
is used for identifying this in our site
component context and I'm like yeah
great that you can identify your
component and I can so please how can I
do it oh yeah I said Bubble Bobble for
the rescue yes
it's Jeremy already crying and so we add
bubble to our system it's another NPM
package and then we top-level did we
have this plug-in and if you don't want
to configure bubble or ourselves because
we are lazy and use create react app or
we don't have access to our context we
can also use bubble macros and import
then the macro instead
of the actual site component and then
finally we have a meaningful readable
name on this thing that doesn't change
every time we load the freaking page so
yes okay but beware our apocalypse
because you once started very meaningful
by creating one component named wrapper
and then you start to add something
general to it to it because it's your
layout things so you add some more CSS
and call it web component and then
somewhere in a block container is
somebody named it again wrapper and edit
more style to it and yeah so I have
again this long class names that nobody
can understand and read and this is to
see this that goes with it but don't
think you will find any of the CSS in
any of the classes you have written on
there because for example I can assure
you that border is not living in la
crapper I don't know where it is coming
from okay web pack so what can you do
for us nothing because web pack is a
bundler and has nothing to do with how
we architect our power system but when
you're all listen to Mike we have some
tools we can use because we can use
naming conventions like BEM
so we can make a card and take hard
image and have modifiers and we also can
use design patterns like atomic design
where we have small big and large things
and if you are combine this we maybe end
up with a design system so architecture
can help us here and so then we maybe
have class name which we have written
ourselves which is then like something
like comment from text field and if you
compare this to this like components
once it's not even that far away so sky
component also uses naming convention
and still uses your names
and then I hear somebody screaming
naming his heart I don't know what I
should name the things my designer comes
up with after a long weekend on the pub
and yeah I have experienced the same so
sometimes my designer comes up and shows
me something and I don't know what I
should frickin name it and then some
people just call it shining our fancy
and then it's the fancy rapper but I
have an utter solution yeah if you can't
name it you don't need it seriously
because when my designer comes up with
something and I only want to call it
fancy rapper I go back to my designer
and ask them some questions like what
problem of our user is this solving is
it maybe a variation of something we
already have or is it a combination of
some things we already have and also
what is it semantic meaning is it a
primary thing is it a call to action
what are we doing and if you two people
or more still not able to answer these
questions and now still not able to find
a name for the thing then please just
get rid of it I promise you you will not
miss it learning's so the generated
names as helpful they might be they also
do a lot of harm especially when you
want to maintain your stuff please
collaborate with your designers makes
things so much easier and yeah pattern
and conventions they're always helpful
no matter if you used our components or
not it will help you keep the oversight
off your coat okay number three props
state I want to have it
I live in JavaScript and I live in a
stateful environment so I have a couple
of buttons and all of them are able to
get inactive and so when they're
inactive they of course have to reflect
the state to my user wire visually okay
the classic approach as we already have
seen is just adding
a couple of classes to it nobody wants
to remember that and it's that we want
yeah having variation on it and then
using the state so this is where we want
to go and sty components is here to help
us because we are in JavaScript so we
can write JavaScript in RS CSS which is
in JavaScript so we can use error
functions and if and more ifs Morris
okay so I think now Mike is crying and I
am crying so but maybe maybe this is all
worth it let's have a look so oh yes we
have one class name yes yes yes and I
don't need to remember this class and
great because there's a so generate it
and I can see the props but somehow I
don't have a connection between the used
attribute and the props so yes and then
my designer comes in and says oh yeah I
have a new variation we now have an
alternative button and I'm getting a
headache web pack so web pack now here
same problem as before where peck
doesn't do anything for you in this case
you just can go back to our architecture
and so we just try to write some BEM
classes with modifiers and then we are
now writing our own higher-order
function component which is now our
button and I'm using a very small tool I
found it very helpful which is called
class names and this is basically just
doing some string operations for me
because I'm lazy and so I have no my
props the same as before variant and the
inactive state and then I use those
class names package where I'm like
combining my classes based on those
props and the state and then I'm just
adding these classes to this component
button component and then I just can't
return it and also there's this very
helpful thing called prop types and
there I can define like
example what variations are possible so
I can expose to everybody that is using
this component what props are there and
what they can use and also I can set
default props which is very helpful if I
just want to use one button without
thinking too much and it is used like
this and that looks like the thing from
the beginning we wanted it looks the
same and rendered it looks like the
thing we didn't want but we don't care
because we didn't write this ourselves
and this is this looks now as we know it
so we have our modifier clusters and we
can clearly see what attribute is
triggered by which modifier so thank you
architecture you helped us yeah so the
learnings here is that there is a hard
way to connect the attributes from CSS
to the attributes you put on our
components so the development tools are
not there yet to support us in this way
so maybe this will change hopefully then
one thing that is dangerous in most
cases which is mixing props that are
only there for styling with props that
are there for functions because
sometimes when you didn't change
something you are not sure entirely
which is triggering a style and which is
triggering a function so this is a
warning I want to just announce for all
solutions then yes again architectural
pattern conventions even though we hope
the tools are going to solve this for us
are always helpful
let's summarize our three effects we
wanted to check so
sty components fast loading but it
definitely comes with a cost of
performance so you have to watch out
what you're doing there web pack yeah
sure a little bit but it's JavaScript so
yeah naming I'm scoping it has good
approach but I'm not too sure about it
so I definitely would not go without
conventions namings architecture as
these
yes and I can use the same architecture
tools for going with whatever other
solution I want the same is for the
props and a styling part and I can use
some little tools like the class names
package to help me solving my
architectural problems to be honest the
prop thingy it really scares me a lot so
I would not use it without any
conventions of patterns so should we use
tools of our conventions and patterns I
say it's not a nor question we can have
both because tools should always support
to retain our patterns and conventions
so tools should not be necessarily there
to solve all your problems but to help
you solving your problems to make it
easy for you to follow the conventions
and parents no matter if you want to
choose now the architecture Mike and I
have shown to you or if you want to come
up with your own solutions in your own
team but as long as we have some and you
have tools that support you you are
going to be great so thank you all for
listening and yeah here's my Twitter
handle maybe we get over 500 at some
point I don't know and if you want to
check out all the things I have done you
can go to the github repository of our
little Park lab experiment and also you
can find the slides there
thank you so much